well throughout this week we have been
sharing with you different updates on
the situation for a las vegas man who is
a former u.s afghani combat interpreter
now his wife is still hiding in
afghanistan and she's not able to get to
the airport kirsten joyce caught up with
a military veteran about what he
believes needs to happen next
we need to go ahead and help the people
that we promised that we would do the
right thing to and we failed to do that
at this point
bill reynolds of henderson is a military
veteran and defense contractor who works
with multiple bases all over the world
he spent his entire adult life involved
with the war in afghanistan making great
friends with afghan people who helped
the united states and now desperately
need our help
the problem though is we have to
negotiate with the taliban to get our
americans and our afghan partners
through the taliban basically a blockade
of the airport and get them
to the airport to get evacuated out we
don't have a deal to do that and right
now the people i'm talking to um you
know interpreters their families uh
doctors that we've worked with in the
past they are all right now hidden in
kabul
you know
trying to get through to that airport
because once they get to the airport
there is a safe way home right there's a
safe way to get to the united states
which is great we've established that
but we have to establish a route for
them to get from wherever they are in
the country not just kabul but all over
the whole country afghanistan's a huge
place and we've left people everywhere
meantime hk the former u.s combat
interpreter who worked for the u.s
military in afghanistan and now lives in
las vegas still trying to get his wife
out of afghanistan safely she has
authorization to be on the flights
leaving kabul but she is one of the many
who remain in hiding from the taliban
unable to reach the airport as a result
she was not able to board the flight
leaving last night we will continue to
keep you updated on hk's situation and
his wives as we follow these
developments i'm kirstjen joyce
well the state department has set up a
hotline with more information if you're
interested in it the phone number here
is
47 888-407-4744 now if you need to call
outside of the united states get this
number to someone that is 202-501-4444
we do have an entire list of
organizations that are offering help and
resources on our website you might find
that helpful at eight newsnow dot com